actually we are planning on making a
book like it's gonna be more like like a
you know independent filmmakers notebook
to you know have your shootings and
things you need to do your things you
don't want to do and you know it's not a
Bible verse based on our experience we
tried many different things and I'm more
you learn something that lets you learn
what what things are not good in any
occasion so what things went wrong with
the corner I guess you know many of the
you know you you can think in advance
what is going to be a success for
example we work in advertising to and
when people come to us and say you know
what I want a viral video you know I say
I can't do a variability for you I'm
sorry you know and and if I if I said to
you that I can I would be lying and
anyone that says to you that can make a
viral video it's going to be lying
because something goes very well you can
make something that has the potential
going viral but you can't make a viral
video it that happens or it doesn't but
you will it will depend on the people
and many other factors so with the
concern was exactly the same we tried
things and we spend money doing for
example a concert now we thought you
know making a concert with eighth grade
Spanish bands thousands of people are
going to come because you know eight
bands it's really cheap i'm at the same
time you are supporting film and okay we
have 800 people which was ok but we have
rented like a 3,000 people place so we
lost money with that it was great for
promotion and we got to you know 800
people coming I was a failure in a way
so we learn okay next time we're gonna
make it small we're going to try to make
it for less people so we makes party we
planet I mean it's like okay it's to
celebrate a thousand producers of the
film we're gonna make a party for I
don't know 400 people's can be small and
you know are something that and a
thousand came so many people will you
know like couldn't get in so you
don't really know it's like the ucomm
plan it depends on how the weather is
that we can depends on how people just
feeling defensive you know it suddenly
released a trailer and that week
something else happens on the net that
you know goes viral you're not gonna get
any attention at the same time you know
you can make something that you're not
planning but people love it and they
start sharing it so you still keep
trying keep trying different things be
created be and and be prepared for
failure and it's like you know when you
have a project and you put all your
cards on one table and it's like okay
all the eggs in one basket we're going
to launch a Kickstarter campaign with
you know everything at the same time
that's cool it might you know it might
be a success but if it comes at the
wrong time and it might not depend on
you you're gonna you know you're gonna
have flown your opportunity so you need
a plan B or to try again later like I
know difficult
you